thousands of people cross it every day
it's the heart of the ukrainian capital
kiev independence square
people often call it just the maidan the
square
has been coming here for more than a
year he's actually from the provinces
but since the beginning of the
revolution in late 2013 the maidan has
been his home
for months there were demonstrations on
the maidan against the autocratic regime
of the pro-russian president viktor
yanukovych
months of protests for democratic reform
since then the maidan has symbolized
that revolution
maxim balenko and his friends were there
from the very start
the square has changed his life
i've understood that my opinion bears
weight i'm worth something i can change
something
nowadays many of the demonstrators of
old crossing the square are soldiers
fighting in eastern ukraine against the
pro-russian separatists
it's at the heart of the capital
and it's now also part of the front in a
way
maxime and his friends are converting a
house here into a hostel for soldiers
passing through
it's symbolic it's an extension of the
protests on the maidan
the war is a major effort for the whole
of ukraine
without the thousands of volunteers it
said the government troops wouldn't have
a chance
after 45 days the soldiers come back
from the east
many stop off here
and can spend the night for free
we're the first to offer them help when
they come to kiev with a warm shower
many want to wash their clothes we give
them civilian clothing if we have it
the one-time revolutionaries are now
hostile staff
the nine friends are renovating more and
more rooms as long as the building
supplies last
even during the protest the most
important thing was being able to
organize yourself we all played a part
and we all understood where our place
was here
for ukrainians the maidan is more than
just the central square in the capital
kiev
it symbolizes the revolution of dignity
as it's called here the revolution that
took place more than a year ago
and it's the central meeting place every
day
and it has other attractions costumed
comic book figures who let you take
their pictures for a tip
pictures on display photographs of the
revolution
they're a reminder of the months of
struggle for democracy in icy winter
temperatures
the first of a hundred victims died
nearby in front of the national library
sergey oliver was in the library from
the very beginning
he and some colleagues set up an
infirmary for the wounded there
surgery was performed on book tables
i hope it brings us some change for the
better
that's what they all hope here on the
maidan and in the entire war-torn
country